the wolf assesses [ __ ]
now I've struck a key my brother's worth
a thousand of your friend your brother
do you love her did Cersei have you
knighted before or after she took you
into her bed
what nothing to say brothers and sisters
where I come from that stain would be
very difficult to wash out
I will not breathe further life into a
malicious lie by discussing there is our
sister how do you think the Sun died her
arms her son don't you could kill a king
lose a hand [ __ ] your own sister you'll
always be the golden careful what you
like down there what that's not your
concern I haven't been with a woman for
years give you a more accurate dog
everything is true Jaime and me no evil
legacy is alive I don't believe you I
don't choose Tywin Lannister I don't
love Tywin Lannister I love my brother
loved one sorry but blonde enough no one
can see us like this I am The Queen for
seven kingdoms I'll do as I please how
do I compare sort of fat King and the
Kings there were fallen on me as has
Jaime repeatedly according to Stannis
Baratheon you're funny but none of your
jokes will ever match the first one will
they she was my mother too how the gun
for the sake of you
I've done nothing quite right you did
nothing when your son called for Ned
Stark's head now the entire North has
risen up against us they tried to stop
it did you you failed that bit of
theater will haunt our family for a
generation you cannot stop it
do you want to see her raped butchered
like the Targaryen children make no
mistake the amount of pretties our head
on a spike right beside yours get out I
don't want you to know what it's like to
love someone to truly love someone
before I take her from you
I promise I will free you don't forget
me never a day will come when you think
you're safe and happy and your joy will
turn to ashes in your mouth and your joy
will turn to ashes in your mouth and you
will know the debt is paid your own
brother said this to you I expect he'll
tell lies about me about Joffrey any
lies in particular you're a clever man
but you're not half as clever as you
think you are still makes me more clever
than you I'm your family who's actively
contributed to that family's survival
but it weren't for my children I'd have
thrown myself a liar's window in the red
key I don't want Casterly Rock and I
would have wife I don't know the
children what do you want seven would be
nice my husband died in a tragic hunting
accident must have been traumatic for my
only daughter was shipped off to Dorne
we suffered through a siege yeah sure
huge rather short siege that I didn't
expect to survive and now I'm marrying
my eldest son to a wicked little [ __ ]
from Highgarden father disowned me today
he can't disown you you all he's God
you're forgetting Tyrion our poor little
brother abused by the world despised by
his father and sister it kill us all if
he could it was Tyrion defend him avenge
our son kill Tyrion he'll squirm his way
to freedom give him the chance
I want him dead I did not kill Joffrey
but I wish that I had watching your
vicious bastard die gave me more relief
than a thousand lying [ __ ] and she
said he killed my mother and she pinched
your little [ __ ] so hard I thought she
might pull it off until your brother
made her stop
he doesn't matter she told us everyone
says he will die soon I hope they are
right he should not have lived this long
I would do things for my family you
couldn't imagine Aryan is your family
he's not you don't get to choose I do so
do you you can choose the creature that
killed our mother to come into this
world to blame him for that you didn't
decide to kill her he was an infant
disease doesn't decide to kill you all
the same you cut it out before it does
when the battle commences you and your
wildlings will be in the vanguard
van Gogh me and the tribesmen on the
front lines only their ways to have me
killed that would be less detrimental to
the war effort it will be no more
discussion on the matter we're still
fertile you need to marry again and
breed
I have Queen Regent not some broodmare
my daughter you will do as I command and
you will marry Loras Tyrell and put an
end to the disgusting rumors about you
once and for all
we do it in another world Margaery will
dig her claws in you we'll take your
claws in and you'll fight over him like
beasts until you rip him apart I will
burn our house to the ground before I
let that happen I know that one of my
three judges has wished me dead more
times than I can count and that judge is
my father and I would let myself be
consumed by maggots before mocking the
family name and making you heir to
Casterly Rock why why you ask that you
are an ill-made spiteful little creature
full of envy lust and low cunning what
you what'll about wearing that proud
lion that was my father's sigil and his
father's before him but neither God's
nor men will ever compel me to let you
turn Casterly Rock into your whorehouse
since I cannot prove that you are not
mine
I wanted to carry you into the sea and
let the waves wash you away hey pop I
was mean to you I killed my mother
Joanna Lannister on the day I was born I
killed my father Tywin Lannister with a
boat to the heart I am the greatest
Lannister killer of our time if you ever
see that we [ __ ]
give him my regards
I have a seal element this internal ones
Toph bran as if I have a Sawyer cannot
cut you enough it'll take you a while
with a sparring sword I am your mother
you can always trust me you can always
trust me I go you've work towards your
entire Jessie I didn't know function of
this family if it weren't for me you'd
have a mother if it weren't for me you'd
have a father if it weren't for me you'd
have two beautiful children I've thought
about killing you more times than I can
count
I always knew you were the stupidest now
I'm the only one you have left our
children are gone her father is gone
it's just me and you now this one more
yet to come